Send them all
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
full Black Adam breakdown and Easter eggs for
the entire movie hopefully you've had a chance to
see it there's a bunch of big stuff they set up a
bunch of sequels obviously a bunch of Cameo scenes
a big post-credits scene we've all been talking
about if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos and obviously
careful for spoilers for the movie because we
have to talk about everything that happened I
also just did a post-credit scene for the big
Superman Henry Cavill post-credit scene with him
coming back in what that means in the dceu I will
address that during this video but I've done like
a much bigger video just about the Superman scene
so I'll link that at the end of this and down in
the description below but the movie is inside
the dceu if it wasn't clear it takes place after
the events of the Justice League movie after the
new Suicide Squad movie obviously and before the
events of Shazam Fury of the Gods also probably
after the events of Peacemaker if you've been
following the DC movies for a long time now you
may remember that they officially cast The Rock
as Black Adam over 10 years ago so a lot of you
are asking why did it take them over 10 years to
make this movie that's mostly because when they
were originally cast the rock as Black Adam like
more than 10 years ago at that time we were still
sort of in the old regime it was still Christopher
Nolan era Batman with Christian Bale the Warner
Brothers people had very different plans about
the future of the DCU and developing all those
characters all the Justice League characters the
future of Superman Batman everybody so at the time
they just didn't know how to fit in an anti-hero
obviously now things are very different the DC
universe itself is very different the actual Black
Adam character debuted inside the original Fawcett
Comics Shazam stories back in 1945 he debuted as
a Shazam villain in the original Shazam family
Comics basically his origin in the movie draws
a little bit from his original origin story like
the very first one back in 1945 and a little bit
from The New 52 version of his origin story with
a couple changes that I'll address when we get to
those parts of the movie in his original origin
story in 1945 in the Marvel family number one
they explained the wizard granted powers to a
person called teth Adam based on at the time it
was Greco-Roman Gods like the Shazam character
but then later they wrecked combat to Egyptian
gods so their power words are both Shazam but the
acronyms stand for different gods in that original
story Black Adam killed the current pharaoh and
then tried to rule the planet himself the wizard
in Revenge basically kicked into the other
side of the universe and it took Black Adam 5
000 years to get back to planet Earth and when
he got back it was present day he fought the
Shazam family the new 52 aspects of his origin
story are everything about his son passing him
his powers and him being trapped in the magical
prison for the last five thousand years originally
their plan was to actually introduce him during
the first shazam movie because that is the new
52 origin story for Shazam the story of Billy
Batson getting his powers is New 52 but during
that instead of just the seven deadly sins being
released Black Adam also gets released and winds
up trying to fight the Shazam family at the end
so you have to imagine the end of the first shazam
movie where they all get the powers and they all
wind up fighting Black Adam instead eventually
they decided to just separate their origin story
so Black Adam became a solo movie and they just
continued with the shazam movie Just substituting
in a lot of Dr Savannah plot eventually they will
have a crossover with Shazam versus Black Adam
but they have to kind of work up to that right
now it seems like they're more focused on Superman
versus Black Adam as you see in the post-credits
scene we'll get there eventually the opening
credits are meant to be similar to the Shazam
opening credits with a darker Vibe because they're
setting him up as an anti-hero the oozing black
liquid running across the logo as it forms is
meant to be a parallel for the end credit scenes
where they show the different character suits
forming with the same kind of oozing metal all
over their suits that's meant to be a reference
to the way that black Adam's suit forms around
him out of magic like Suboxone doctor Fates
and hawkman's in everyone else's forming with
nanites basically the movie actually starts with
a flashback to his original time and khandaq 5000
years ago to explain his origin story in the dceu
like I said couple minor tweaks to his backstory
they don't give you the entire story to a little
bit later in the movie but the whole idea is that
in the dceu kondok was meant to be the center of
civilization like the first major civilization 5
000 years ago looking at the entire dceu timeline
you remember that the Dark Side War happened 10
000 years ago so like Atlantis existed before
khandaq so technically there were civilizations
before khandaq Wonder Woman is also just a little
bit older than Black Adam she's a little bit over
5000 years old and if you really want to
dig into deep history making more Superman
references because of the big Superman Henry
Cavill post credit scene the Kryptonian ship
that he winds up finding in Man of Steel is
over 20 000 years old so technically that's
like the oldest artifact we've found next to the
actual rock of Eternity because there's a lot of
teasers for other untold history that they don't
totally explain during the movie like setting up
big plot points that they'll cover in the sequels
the current king of his day forces them to mine
eternium which are fragments of the rock of
Eternity that have fallen to Earth that only exist
in khandaq in their current form they have magical
properties they're like laced with magic which
is how inter gangs Tech runs on it has all those
special properties and how they can use eternium
weapons to harm Black Adam here's where we start
setting up the sequel movies the reason why there
would be fragments of the rock of Eternity
in khandaq before the events of this movie
like that they're buried in the earth and they've
been there for a long time is there had been some
ancient battle that the Wizards had before this
that they don't get into in the movie that they'll
cover in the sequels I actually think it was the
Wizards fighting eclipso because if you remember
the original teaser for the movie they had like
a completely different plot eclipso was a big
part of it like you have eclipso's gem here next
to Black Adam in the flashback during that scene
to ancient khandaq you see this giant explosion
happen and then they show all the eclipso stuff
so I think the idea is that eclipso attacked the
rock of Eternity and that would cause shards of it
to fall to khandaq in the comics it's a little
bit different Dr Savana accidentally created
eternium when he attacked the rock of Eternity
and that's what caused the fragments to fall to
Earth black Adam's son is chosen to be the next
Champion by the Council of wizards at the time
who Grant him the powers from all the gods that
are different from the Shazam Gods like I said
based more on Egyptian mythology and when they
Grant him Powers even though they don't show
him till a little bit later in the movie his
outline is made to look just like comic book
Black Adam with a very special looking haircut he
winds up passing his power to his father or just
like Billy Batson did with the shazamly at the end
of their first movie but instead of granting him
a portion of his power he gives all of his power
leaving himself weak and able to be killed by the
King's Men Black Adam then kills the king all
those men in Revenge and The Wizard traps Black
Adam for five thousand years after his powers get
out of control and threaten to destroy the world
in the comics the difference is that black Adam's
nephew was the one who got the powers whose name
was Amon five thousand years ago and he killed
his nephew after he tricked him into giving
him his powers so comic book Black Adam was way
more irredeemable than the movie version in the
movie they also give the Iman name to Adrianna
tomaz' son the former King had been using the
eternium to craft the magical crown called the
crown of sabbac who is from the Shazam comics
like those original Fawcett era 1940s comics
in sabak is basically like an evil version
of Shazam the zabach name is also an acronym
just like the Shazam name and stands for six
different demon evil gods that Grant the powers
to this person his acronym stands for Satan aim
Belial Beelzebub asmodius and cradius so later in
the movie when Ishmael is being granted the powers
of these different demons that's basically who
you're seeing all the different demons there are
the ones that are part of the acronym the trick
that they pull though is that the demons are just
using their sabach Champion as a finger puppet
to create a conduit to the main DCEU Dimension so
that they can conquer it the symbol of the three
triangles that shows up throughout the timeline
like the slave symbol in the past and Adrianna's
eternium necklace in the future is meant to be a
reference to the normal citizens of khandaq in
general like a symbol of the slaves themselves
that they use to unite in his son and then later
Amon uses big rallying cries the actual Black
Adam name is something that Adrianna's son winds
up helping him come up with just saying that his
teth Adam name is very outdated that is his real
name like his birth name that he was given so he
just calls himself that through most of the film
until the end in the present day of the movie in
the dceu kondok is being controlled by intergang
who are secretly being used by Ishmael the Last
Descendant of that original King to reclaim the
crown of Sabbath can take his powers eater gang
is like a whole big separate evil organization
that you probably recognize from some of the
comics or the young justice TV series they're an
Intergalactic evil organization with Lex Luthor
working in partnership with Darkseid for those of
you that want to see more Darkseid in the DCEU but
just to be clear everything that Ishmael was doing
inside inner gang was him going rogue on his own
using a portion of their forces like the larger
inner Gang has their hands and a lot more pies
around the world so we'll probably see inner gang
and other future things like this isn't the end of
inner gang by any means when we first meet Amon
he's wearing a red hoodie which is meant to be a
reference to Billy Batson Shazam because they want
him to feel just like Billy Batson even though
in the movie they use him a little bit more like
Freddie Freeman because both of them are superhero
Justice League Fanboys Amon has Justice League
merch all over his room comic books posters action
figures even real life comic books everything is
based on real life DC merch that you could go out
to a store and buy a lot of the art that they use
a lot of the action figures and posters they use
are from different arrows of the comics that's why
some of the logos look a little bit different like
this isn't Ben Affleck's Batman logo this looks
a little bit closer to Michael Keaton's Batman
logo he has some Jim Lee Batman art you have some
rebirth era cyborg comics for those of you wanting
more cyborg in the DCEU the whole idea is that
the Justice League Heroes have just become pop
culture icons so a lot of merch is being created
around them so the idea is that DC Comics does
exist inside the dceu it's the same thing in the
Marvel movies too like there is a company inside
the Marvel movies that's named Marvel Studios that
creates Marvel comic books as well but basically
you see merge from all the main Justice League
Heroes the only one I didn't feel like I saw
Easter eggs for here was Green Lantern there were
Green Lantern Easter eggs though in the Shazam
Fury of the Gods trailer video so that means
that there is Green Lantern stuff happening in
this universe if there's merch being created about
the character I also think a mod being in the red
hoodie foreshadows Black Adam eventually giving
him a portion of his powers like Billy Batson
did along with Adrianna Tomaz like they basically
set up him granting them Powers creating his own
version of the Shazam family which is something
that they did a lot in the comics also him in
the red and wearing the red cape later foreshadows
the Superman post-credits scene with Henry Cavill
we meet Adrianna Tomaz who's a long time love
interest of Black Adam in the comics they do
eventually get married in the dceu she worked at
a local University in khandaq she studies history
which is how she knows everything about the
eternium the crown of sabak how she could read the
ancient khandaq language on black Adam's prison
she's also kind of a freedom fighter too they use
the first big action scene when she releases
him to show you his basic Powers but the soft
explainer on that pretty easy is that his powers
are exactly like shazam's Powers we find out
that Amanda Waller has been monitoring everything
knows about Black Adam getting out of his prison I
believe she knows what inner gang is doing like
she's been monitoring them she knows about the
eternium that they use in its value but it sounds
like she doesn't totally know what's going on with
the actual crown of sabok and what Ishmael has
planned the reason she calls the Justice Society
instead of the Justice League at first is just
because she doesn't think the problem was big
enough to require Superman others like she refers
to them later in the movie as an even bigger favor
that she has to call in also in the comics Black
Adam has way more history with the Justice Society
characters than the Justice League so on a story
level it just made more sense to start with the
Justice Society and they want to grow the DCEU as
much as possible which requires them introducing
a bunch of new characters so it just made more
sense to use those characters than to start out
with the Justice League the movie only gives us
a little backstory on the original version of the
Justice Society team they said that was on purpose
and they'd explain characters origins in future
movies and spin-offs but on the DCEU Earth they
implied that the Justice Society used to be a big
thing 30-40 plus years ago when all the characters
were very young with the exception of Doctor Fate
and Hawkman who either had their lives extended by
the helmet of fate in his powers or in the case of
Hawkman reincarnate the original version of the
atom on that team was played by Henry Winkler
who's obviously an old man also Cyclone's mother
is the original Red Tornado and she was on that
original Justice Society team the way they're
explaining Doctor Fate in this movie is they're
going with the more Cosmic origin story not the
one that you saw during Young Justice with Vandal
Savage in this version of the origin story the
original one Kent Nelson was a Swedish American
who discovered the tomb of Naboo with his father
having accidentally killed his father due to
a deadly gas the Lords of order felt pity for
him and trained him in the ways of magic for a
couple of decades then bequeathed him his mystical
Amulet the helmet of Fate the cloak as well as his
knowledge before he started his career as Doctor
Fate the Lords of Order and Chaos are primordial
forces in the DCEU that existed at the dawn of
creation that kind of existed in an alternate
Dimension and influence all of reality in the
dceu the origin story for Naboo who basically is
the spirit inside the helmet of Fate is that he's
one of the descendants of the Lords of order who
manifested themselves as the first sentient race
in the universe on this other planet Naboo was one
of their descendants and he eventually traveled to
planet Earth and became an advisor to the ancient
pharaohs of the day so in the movie when they say
the helmet of Fate came from another planet that's
what they're talking about hawkman's backstory is
way more more complicated in the comics so we'll
see how they explain it in the DCEU they might
go with the hawkworld origin story or they might
go with the archaeologist or the resurrection
backstory the basic idea is that he's a member of
this ancient thanagarian race who's got a version
of Amnesia and reincarnates over time and is
bonded to the nth metal like the nth metal comes
from thanagar it's sort of like the DC version
of vibranium they did say that Hawkgirl was part
of the movie at one point but they decided to do
something else with the character we'll probably
meet her in either sequels or some other future
DC movie but she is inside the DCEU somewhere they
also explained that he's the person who owns the
Justice Society mansion and his Mansion is meant
to be like the classic Justice Society Mansion the
vibe they're going with in the movie though is
that it's a little bit more like the X-Mansion
in those original X-Men movies because he has this
whole jet underneath the backyard the current Atom
Smasher is the nephew of the original atom smasher
using his original costume that's why he keeps
saying that it's retro they'll probably give him
a new suit in one of the future movies in the same
way that Ant-Man started out in the first Ant-Man
movie wearing in the original suit and then got a
new one in the sequels Cyclone is meant to be the
granddaughter of the original Red Tornado who was
on that original Justice Society team when she
was younger she was captured by the scientists
who created the second Android version of Red
Tornado who injected her with nanites giving her
her powers they're basically exactly what you see
in the movie wind control the youth are kind of
like a version of Storm from the X-Men on the team
I already explained all the Justice League Easter
eggs around Amon's room but part of the comedy
here too is him blasting Superman's picture in
action figures everywhere he goes That's just to
foreshadow them fighting in the sequels like if
all the things that he could have destroyed in
Amon's room he destroys just the Superman stuff
when he busts into the living room the Clint
Eastwood movie playing on the TV is The Good
the Bad and the Ugly later in the movie they
referenced Clint Eastwood's man with no name
character again like they referenced the events
of the film again when Black Adam fights the
inner gang soldiers using his magical lightning
as if he were the Clint Eastwood man with no name
character they also play the theme song from that
movie when he's doing that just to set him up as
an anti-hero because Clint Eastwood's man with no
name character was a big anti-hero as well we get
another Cameo scene from Emilia Harcourt this time
last seen during the events of Peacemaker because
she's working with Amanda Waller again it seems
like they're on relatively good terms I think we
can assume that they put their differences aside
but when they lock Black Adam up there's a bunch
of other DC Villains that are also locked up there
under that polar ice cap prison it's really quick
blink on you'll miss it it's a little too blurry
so I have to wait for like an HD copy of the movie
to come out so we can zoom and enhance a little
bit easier and see exactly what they have there
but if you think you spotted any of these other
DC Villains that were in the prison write in
the comments below Adam Smasher gives Amon the
red cape like I said foreshadowing the Superman
Cameo scene in the post credits and foreshadowing
him getting his own powers from Black Adam in the
sequels and when Black Adam reactivates his powers
again this time his suit regenerates as if it were
brand spaking new like previously they'd implied
that his older costume he'd been wearing for the
past five thousand years in his prison and it
just suffered a lot of wear and tear so that's
why it looks like there was so much battle damage
and the colors were so faded also the new costume
is meant to look a little bit more comic book
accurate like he has the comic book cape on too
Doctor Fate winds up sacrificing himself and even
though the helmet disintegrates really what was
happening if you've read any of the comics is
that it transported itself to its next wielder
like selecting the next person to become Doctor
Fate in the comics the second version of the
character was named Eric Strauss but we'll
see who they wind up using in the DCEU when
the character comes back and then we get our big
post-credits scene Cameo scene with Henry Cavill
Superman returning and I've already done a much
bigger video about this but the whole idea is that
Amanda Waller is basically putting Black Adam on
notice like you step out of khandaq you step out
of line we're going to call in bigger favors with
more powerful people from other planets like you
are not the most powerful person in the universe
maybe on the planet but not in the universe when
he shows up they play the classic John Williams
Superman theme he looks a little bit more like
comic book Superman with the hair curl his colors
are a little tuned up but it's the classic colors
of the costume for those of you asking too who's
more powerful Shazam or Black Adam the way they're
using the characters right now Black Adam is more
powerful because he's not sharing his power with
anyone else like he has a hundred percent of the
available power given to him whereas Shazam only
has a fraction of it because he's giving the rest
of it to the rest of the shazamly the whole idea
with the post credit scene though is that it's
meant to directly set up sequels in the future of
Superman in the dceu so Black Adam 2 like I said
in my post-credits scene video might draw a little
from the comics where Black Adam grants powers to
Amon and Adrianna and things go off the rails like
Amon winds up doing something bad Superman gets
involved because he's worried about the rest of
the planet and because he lays hands on him on
Black Adam gets pissed off at him and that's why
they fight like this very Captain America Civil
War type of situation they're also developing
Man of Steel too and they also have Justice
League two coming up that they plan on making
which will involve the Shazam characters which
includes Black Adam now as well but if you have
any big questions about plot points or big Easter
eggs or references you spotted in the movie that
I didn't talk about in the video just write them
Below in the comments and I'll talk a little bit
more about Black Adam versus Shazam when we get to
more Shazam Fury the god stuff that'll be dropping
early next year we'll probably get a couple more
trailers for that pretty soon soon my next big
video will be for the house of the dragon episode
10 finale everyone click here for that I'll update
the link as soon as I post it and click here
for that Black Adam Superman post-credits scene
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!